s
qu'une étude pancanadienne
se penche sur l'accès
à la réparation et
les résultats sont clairs :
selon un rapport d'Équiterre,
les Canadiens sont de moins en
moins enclins à faire réparer
les produits qu'ils achètent.
- J'essaye, en tout cas,
quand c'est possible.
- Le problème, c'est
que des fois, ça coûte
plus cher de le réparer.
- En 2018, le recours
à la rétait de 22 %
au Canada. Il est maintenant
de 19 %, une baisse notable.
AMÉLIE CÔTÉ, analyste en
réduction à la source, Équiterre
- Ce qu'on a observé, c'est
qu'au Québec, les gens réparent
un petit peu plus aussi,
donc on est vers 25 %.
- Moi, je répare tout le temps
mes affaires, là, j'ai réparé
mon char... tout ce qui brise,
j'essaye le plus possible.
- N'empêche, nombreux sont
les obstacles à la réparation.
- Les appareils sont moins
durables, sont plus difficiles
à ouvrir, on a moins accès
aux outils, aux pièces aussi.
- Tanguy Marker, lui,
a décidé de faire  de faire  dez
à l'obsolescence programmée.
En 2017, il a importé l'idée
du Repair Café à Montréal.Il s's
pour permettre aux gens
d'apprendre à réparer
leurs appareils défectueux.
TANGUY MARQUER, instig. du volet
montréalais, Repair Café de Mtl
- Quand t, c'est
vraiment un... un sentiment
d'euphorie, de satisfaction,
d'avoir réussi à réparer
un objet qui était voué
à finir aux vidanges.
- Malgré le succès de
l'initiative, certains produits
demeurent irréparables puisque
les pièces de rechange sont
tout simplement inaccessibles.
ALEXANDRE PLOURDE, avocat et
analyste, Option consommateurs
- Le com le fabricant
peut tout simplement échapper
à son obligation de fournir des
pièces de rechange simplement
en avisant le consommateur,
lors de l'achat, qu'il ne
fournit pas de services de
réparation, qu'il ne fournit
pas de pièces de rechange.
- Amélie Côté souhaite
que Québec inscrive
le droit à la réparation
dans la Loi de la protection
du consommateur afmmateur afmmae
lui donner plus de mordant.
- On parle, en France,
d'un indice de réparabilité
qui est une note sur 10 qui
est affichée sur les appareils
et qui nous permet d'avoir de
l'information sur à quel point
l'objet est réparable.
- Selon l'étude, 75 % des
Canadiens se disent en faveur
d'une législation favorisant
le droit à la réparation.
i Hassin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.